bionics the enhancement of the human
body with cutting-edge technology
merging man with machine once science
fiction/fantasy it's now a global
industry in Europe's most far-flung
nation a bionic revolution is underway
it's as new as it gets an extension the
human neuro system they are attempting
to build powerful machines that can be
integrated into the human body
controlled by just thought alone they
could change all our lives we're getting
closer and closer and now it's just a
matter of time
one woman at the forefront of the
growing bionics industry is Hilda Ines
Katya as a young girl growing up dolls
and Barbies were not really my thing but
Lego was being able to play around with
these robotic arms and and kind of
understand how they function
Hilda's dream is to engineer a bionic
system that works as intuitively as her
own body
working with the human body on a sort of
biomechanical level that makes you
realize how perfectly created it is and
we have the perfect sample of where we
want to get to in terms of function
that's the human leg we're quite far
along but as part of my job to push the
boundaries further and further
Hildur is part of the team at author one
of the many companies involved in this
emerging industry asar has developed
some of the most sophisticated
prosthetic limbs on the planet they are
now taking the technology a step further
by integrating modern electronics into
the human body
they're building the world's first brain
controlled bionic leg joint by joint
then we got the log okay 48 year old
gummy lost his lower leg over a decade
ago last year he agreed to take part in
an experiment gummy had sensors
surgically inserted into his stump to
link his central nervous system to a
robotic ankle our subconscious brain
controls movement by sending signals to
the appropriate muscles gummies implants
convert those signals into electrical
impulses that then move is Bionic foot
just cool it's the only thing I can
ascribe with it it's just amazing
feeling all over suddenly just sit here
and you can go mmm
I could do this and you can see your
ankle move just like this one I can move
this one and I can move this one just
thinking about it and always it's
strange sometimes I even forget that I
have a prosthetic good the team are now
trying to combine the brain control
technology with their latest innovation
a robotic knee joint with as much
turning power as a harley-davidson so
it's gonna take us about what 10 minutes
more a little bit longer maybe yeah okay
engineer David Ansen has been working on
the power knee for the last five years
yeah it's probably like a racing car
after prosthetic world it does give you
the power it compensates for the muscles
that you've already lost so standing up
from a chair instead of having to do it
on your on your sound side you can do it
on both knees or both legs David is the
ultimate Bionic engineer
being an engineer on your own body gives
you a different perspective than other
engineers being able to work on my own
leg trying to improve it and make it do
the things that I feel it should do it's
extremely exciting our knees are the
most hard working joints in our bodies
essential to everyday activities like
walking running sitting and standing
creating a fully functioning knee joint
is crucial to the dream of building a
perfectly lifelike bionic leg if you had
the brain connected to the prosthesis
and you think now I want the need to
start walking up stairs and they will
just do it for you just intuitively as
you would if you didn't have the
amputation
faced with such a tough engineering
challenge Hilda has carefully selected
the perfect candidate to trial the brain
controlled bionic knee and along with
her colleague she's heading deep into
the Icelandic countryside to visit him
oh I think the favorite you always hope
that the have been completely smashed in
his leg
farmer David Ingerson has a physical job
that will push their engineering to the
limit
last year he had brain controlled senses
surgically inserted into his leg hi hi
good to see you thank you the boot was
on the table and there was no wiring
nothing just some sensors on me and some
soft afferent they okay now move the
foot and I didn't and that was amazing
the feeling was a really really special
I almost get to tyrannize but I'm from
Iceland so you know I get the feeling
right yeah all right I'm good when you
are David senses will soon be linked the
new Bionic knee and then we speed it up
and he's coming for a fitting in a few
days time it's really great to be asked
to to be the first person to do this
because I think that's gonna be a
breakthrough it's great
modern prosthetics are leveling the
playing field for amputees the team at
Acer believe their Bionic technology
also has the potential to reduce the
impact of aging and help us all stay
mobile for longer people are becoming
more independent as they grow older and
so people that were maybe sitting in a
sofa 20 years ago they would now be
going skiing so the need for technology
to assistant and allow that is obvious
92 year old Gunnar is the team's oldest
test user six months ago he was fitted
with his first bionic leg it's such a
valuable thing for us to be able to work
with him on our new projects because he
gives us feedback for that kind of age
group that you know will we so need to
cater for this shows that you have
walked three to four kilometers an hour
pretty good for your age you think so
yes I think so
that's about the same speed as me and
he'll to walk know as our elderly
population grows so will the global
bionics industry extending the life of
aging limbs and restoring the function
of damaged ones in the next five years
alone the industry is expected to exceed
20 billion US dollars in sales makes all
the difference
Palmer's
keeps you alive
for Hilda and the team it's crunch time
today we're meeting David the farmer
again in order to prepare for when we
can connect his brain control device to
the powered prosthesis so that's a
really exciting feeling is I think so oh
but it's gonna work well let's see again
this as new as it gets to make a machine
work us intimately with with it with the
amputee as possible giving the user the
total control over the power provided by
the pony is something that I've never
seen before
we do as much preparation it's possible
but you never really know if it's really
going to work or or not so maybe yeah
or might fix yourself thing so we might
want to just start off slowly how does
that feel when you're standing up do you
feel the power
yeah I really feel the power and it's
really helped you to get out of this
year okay and not too much it's not
nothing
not too much just fine okay so let's see
if we get on okay you okay with this
it's quite high I'm quite steep trust me
Arthur's really good able to go much
faster time right to see him operate the
system and make use of it being the only
one in the world doing so is is really
brilliant he's good
we were just scratching the surface of
what this technology can do so I'm
convinced that in the next 15 years
we're going to see a giant leap
you